weird because of this movie and x-men
you have no hair a lot like your ball
very smooth are you scared that your
eventually your hair will get tired of
going back if you want to look closely
you see that it might be oh no it's
gonna get little fatigued getting to the
age of 40 pause receiving through
singing can't Eli yeah it's just quite
like it that would be honest with you
yeah wait like shaving my head okay yeah
so you do quite like shaving like how
old were you when you used your
grandfather's razor oh no how old was a
grand a year someone here I can't
remember what it was
where's worship and dad available I
think it might have been a bit way over
13 I don't know I was younger than that
I was getting pubes gotten past point
three I tried the plat shaving I saw I
basically got enough of them that I
thought I don't know if I want this for
my future so I'm gonna I'm gonna that
was bored one day and and I saw my
grandma's reason I thought oh I'll have
a bang at that and then and I start
shipping off I did it badly and I
stopped quickly and I cut myself a
little bit bleed and so I got some
tissue and I dabbed it and I just like I
was blood in a chocolate in the toilet
cleaned it was the not and I went up the
stairs and about ten minutes later I
just hear James James and I'm like
company top the stairs I'm like AHA and
they're like can come down here for
viewing it son that was like a horrible
start something you were like you're
right and I was like yeah I'm fine
why what's up and they were like you're
right and I was like yeah I'm alright
and like James are you okay and I was
like I'm alright they're like does blood
in the toilet no guy and this razor and
I think they were worried that
really sure like shows your dresses are
you doing
[Applause]
in mortified look on their faces was
kind of like as no
there was a stunned silence you were and
then after they collected themselves my
granny so took me aside and explained to
me things about hygiene in her he's
going to be using that in his face and
stuff like that oh good point Ronnie
yeah
[Music]
you